There are about 3,000 restaurants specializing in fugu in Tokyo today.
From the outside, they're usually easy to recognize and they're always highly specialized.
One of them is Rikizo Okamoto's restaurant...
...where sometimes even prime ministers drop by.
Uosei is its name, the pure fish place.
You also need a license to prepare fugu.
The poison in fugu is tetrodotoxin.
It's 1,000 times more potent than cyanide and there is no antidote.
The poison paralyzes its victims but leaves them fully conscious.
Proper preparation is critical: the skin and entrails of the fish are poisonous...
...and they must not contaminate the nontoxic meat on the muscles.
A real fugu meal consists of at least six courses.
This ultimate in gourmet pleasures is mainly enjoyed in Japan...
...when there is something to celebrate.
Nowadays, the chances of being poisoned at a fugu restaurant are practically zero...
...thanks to the high demands placed on the chefs.